je suis scandalisée je vais vous
expliquer pourquoi la représentation
sous forme de cadeaux parce que j'ai
bien dit choyé il aurait pu
la représentation des juifs sous forme
de caricature c'est un des fondements de
l'antisémitisme sa légitime les
persécutions avec des stéréotypes
abjecte et moi je vous le dis très
franchement très crûment la france
insoumise tentent de dire c'est une
représentation d'une figurine de
carnaval etc il tente de trouver des
paravents c'est une s'excuse pas ma
seule conclusion c'est que la france a
soumises en tant qu'institution et
antisémites voilà ah oui c'est vrai vous
le saviez pas d'accord je n'ai pas
d'autres mots les enfants répond je suis
pas moi je n'arrive pas à voir moi je
vois un personnage qu'on a rendu méchant
on est amis des yeux d un sourire
méchant un écran j'arrive pas à me dire
moi parce qu'on fait parce que c'est un
et crochus c'est un juif parce que il
est black alors c'est un singe parce
qu'il est ce si j'arrive pas à rentrer
dans les cases les gens comme ça mais
pour moi j'y vois pas une représentation
d'un buffet mollema qu'on les juifs non
je crois que ça va les manuels mâcon
j'arrive à une représentation là dedans
moi
expliquez moi aussi c'était dans mes la
raison raymond parce qu on
comprendre parce que c'est vrai qu'à
plein de gens qui ont dit comme raymond
voillat ces archétypes de la caricature
du juif capra l'argent et qui d'une
caricature qui date des années 30 qui a
été dans toutes les tombes dans le grand
dreyfus avant et même la sphère dreyfus
à vendre au 19e s'est à chaque fois
qu'on représente le juif pour le
caricaturer pour dire qu'il est proche
de l'argent et que c'est qu'un être
cynique et veulent qu'on leur présente
avec les mains comme ceux qui qui sont
comme s'il allait prendre des billets
d'argent et le nez crochu c'est
typiquement dans la caricature
antisémite des années 30 la façon de les
manier
je suis fâché pour lesquelles on a vu
mon accent si toujours macro aussi à la
banque rothschild mais en dix ans la
banque leur accord etc on
dit qu'il a la rage et mathieu toujours
pas vu une seule seconde franchement
effectivement quand on fait un méchant
la sorcière de blanche neige l'année
comme ça quand on fait un méchant le
fait méchant il est pas juif il n'est
pas ultra libérale y'a pas l'anti
d'identité ni d'antisémitisme chez
mélenchon pardon
c'est le seconde où on peut voir ça dans
cette caricature à la pardon mais pas
une seule seconde investiture à vis du
rallye non moi je suis complètement
d'accord avec gilles et je remercie
d'ailleurs gilles de dire ça ce soir je
n'en reviens pas il ya effectivement
dans la france en soumises parfois une
ambiguïté leers alors évidemment je vais
pas dire la france insoumise et
antisémite parce que ce serait
diffamatoire mais il ya une ombre je
vous aime parfois dans leur dos oui toi
tu l'as dit moi je vais pas dire je vais
pas aller jusque là mais des choses pas
très claires par exemple il ya eu la
commémoration ce week end 2 2 celle de
mohamed merah et là encore une fois les
mots ne sont pas utilisés on dit pas que
c'est des attentats des islamistes on
dit que ce sont des barbares antisémite
c'est à dire que ça tourne toujours
autour du pot parce qu'on est en période
électorale et on veut un peu draguer un
certain un certain électorat et c'est
absolument dégueulasse donc oui il ya un
roland antisémite parfois au niveau de
la france a soumis et c'est pour ça
justement mathieu que tu dis y'a pas de
l'antisémitisme et s'il y en a dans
plein de propos de mélenchon sur zemmour
il avait sorti aussi des trucs très beau
recadre donc on peut condamner les idées
de zemmour mais pour autant ne pas
tomber dans l'antisémitisme dans une
autre vidéo qui a énormément fait réagir
on y voit une manifestante avoir des
propos lors de la manifestation qui ont
été relevés regarder si ça vous choque
pas
[Musique]
terrorisme boycott
voilà coloniale les
colonials
ginel criminels aussi qui a pratiqué
pratique n'est pas qui s'est construit
sur un nettoyage
alors
raymond voillat et moi je voudrais
guillaume mais là c'est de la
manipulation on prend les propos d'une
manifestante ont en effet posé sur tout
un party moi mais ça
écourte où il a raison
on fait surtout un parti bien je suis en
trouve ça extrêmement graves de créer de
l'antisémitisme là où il y en a pas
c'est une carte du racisme comme on en a
vu voilà voilà c'est exact c'est le
propre des pierres la capture c'est que
les traits soit groupe si quasiment
toutes les caricatures ont un gros nez
d'autres caricatures des manuels à
savoir s'ils vont vous expliquer alors
qui est plein de gens qu'ils aient
relevé ils ont les mêmes al
thani
la france a soumis son et répondant tu
sais un parc daniel gagnier non mais
c'est juste juste une chose faire un
parti qui est régulièrement montré du
doigt 8% pour justement une sorte de
double langage et de et de survie à
chaque fois ils viennent sur les
plateaux dire mais non pas du tout mais
en même temps chaque fois ils remettent
une couche derrière bien sûr il convient
de mettre un euro dans la machine monde
des affaires je suis désolé le paillage
soul c'est à dire faire sauter comme ça
un pantin c'est une tradition est vrai
ma mission dans le tas fait le carnaval
de nice j'ai regardé d'autres images
mais emmanuel macron a déjà été en pente
inverse où il avait un gros nez il avait
un grand nez mais il n'avait pas un et
crochus le nez crochu bizarrement ça se
trouve dans une manifestation de la
france info 1000 qui flirte en même
toujours dangereusement avec
l'antisémitisme moi je pense que ce
n'est pas hasard voilà d'autant plus que
d'après les chiffres du ministère de
l'intérieur il ya une montée alarmante
des agressions antisémites il assure
donc faut pas jouer avec ça a dû lui
demander aux 10 9% du public s'ils sont
antisémites pour la france
mx1 jil jilala
on a les hauts dirigeants en ont ensuite
la l'ambiguïté justement de mélenchon
qui sort sur des vagues justement pour
draguer un certain lectorat voilà est
vraiment confiant je te penches parce
que je n'arrive pas à comprendre enfin
j'essaye de comprendre mais j'ai peur
d'une faute pas la première fois que je
suis con mais quand c'est un laurent
venir moi je n'en mets quand c'est un
noir qui en singe tout le monde il n'en
faut pas voir le noir en singe a hélas
quand on a un nez crochu à 600 juifs je
comprends pas pourquoi je comprends bien
on fait ça on a fait le même si je
parlais les suspects marchandise à un
singe gonflables à au rayon des kiwis
wave a dit non mais faut pas voir le
racisme là dedans faut pas voir que
parce qu'il est noir c'est un saint
c'est pas vrai et là parce qu'on met de
marionnettes qui est méchante avec un
nez crochu ben c'est pas bien c'est pas
bien ce qu'ils font ça veut dire qu'il
est juif mais maquereau ou pas juif mais
j'arrive pas à comprendre en fait on met
de 96,6 où il y en a pas en fait il ya
je pense que c'est ça qui est dangereux
ça devient dangereux de penser comme ça
à chaque fois au moins peut-on gagner
qui n'est pas juif ça s'est arrêté